[Musique]
nous
je m'appelle année marquée sos vélo
[Musique]
m'asseoir sur une chaire ses de la vente
et c'est pas pour moi
ces manuels c'est physique un peu aussi
rose poudré souvent les mêmes
j'ai sos vélo on va pas juste de la
l'opération de vélos usagés com
qu'est-ce que je fais un euro le slip
avons vraiment la fin de ces
informations n'a pu être étayée voit
toute la peinture sans m6 à la mène au
métal dur ici pour ses portes peu après
mais comme pro
[Musique]
je suis payé pour information c'est à
salaire minimum est quand même bien
simple part de madame à mettre sur pied
je suis nouveau brunswick j'habite à
québec 6 ie6
avant d'être l'hôte du canadien je
travaillais par l'entretien des puits de
pétrole à cause de séparation je suis
revenu à mon égard je vais pas les
moyens pour me koné mamadou et où elle
n'a pas traîné
mais voilà il ya des jobs à construire
cette odeur
j'étais aux bruits machine refuge pour
les hommes à montréal au centre qui
venait abel vraiment que je me trouvais
une cup
j'ai appliqué chez autres la source peut
louer non engagé
moi même j'étais un amateur de vélo by
j'ai toujours voulu savoir de a à z
comme comment qu'on va parler vélo
en étant ici je vois toutes les types
d'outils différents voilà paré vélo que
c'est pas tout le monde dans l'équipe
est ma meilleure
les formateurs sont vraiment bons ils
connaissent ce qui pèse on peut demander
des questions car sous le coeur c'est
bien parce qu'on n'est pas sûr toujours
content de la pause
[Musique]
ok
quand je prends le soin jeu bien content
de ce que j'ai accompli puisque ce que
j'ai appris
mais je viens van hoecke
d'avoir une bonne ultime dhabi ça m'aide
à ce stade
[Musique]
une bonne la gombe